the golden knights prepare for a long
stretch of hockey away from vegas
tonight is the first of two games
at san jose john treach has a preview of
the sharks versus the knights hey john
hey there kirsten the golden knights
begin a stretch of playing six road
games in nine days already you get the
sense
there is tension between the sharks and
knights for this first bout tonight
so don't be surprised if both are doing
a few extra arm curls for a pre-game
pump
and watching rocky 4 before getting on
the ice this one matters
the sharks famously knocked the knights
out of the playoffs in 2019 the knights
have consistently
knocked san jose out of their skates in
every other circumstance
the two franchises are going in
diametrically
opposite directions but on a friday
night on the ice
they share one mission pummel each other
and worry about mercy and feelings later
they're trying to manufacture a emotion
on their end
and you know it's based around
a hit that the referees on the ice
didn't deem illegal and player safety
after looking at it
800 times didn't deem illegal so you
know i guess whatever you got to do to
get yourself going
you know we we have a team can play any
way you want to play
we'll go from there and i think on
nights like tonight we can all learn
from cobra kai strike first strike hard
no mercy
kirsten gets this the puck drops at 7 30
and we'll have complete reaction at 11.